all right this morning we're
reconnecting with a grammy-nominated
hip-hop group called the alphabet
rockers jamie yukis has been following
these 12 and 13 year olds since just
before the pandemic now
as kids head back to school their
message about diversity and privilege is
timely so take a listen as these rockers
sing about standing up to racism and
breaking down barriers
there is something that i might need you
to do it's the jam right here just
because you say we need equality too
e is for equality if you don't look like
me will you stay on my back and what
you're hearing is no illusion the
alphabet rockers rap about inclusion
[Music]
the pre-teens began contributing to the
lyrics hoping to inspire kids to wake up
and stand up for
[Music]
do you others you can change the world
yes most definitely you do
yeah it's a new generation things change
the group was founded by caitlin mcgaw
and tommy solati shepherd
who teamed up to tackle discrimination
there's no words to describe
what our country will turn into if we
don't turn it around the music is a
chance for us to be on that journey
together and say yes your voice matters
we first met the kids in a recording
studio after their album earned them a
second grammy nomination
cove had forced them to take their
message online people get judged for who
they are most adults think that we're
supposed to just sit back and be cute
but we have powerful ideas and we can
use those to create a better world
they created an anti-racism course for
families in the hope of sparking
conversations about equity empathy and
race for folks who haven't been engaging
in this conversation might be a little
harder but it's definitely necessary
racism is the reason why i've gotten
teased about my skin color and
gotten told things such as you're too
dark to play with us
as protesters filled the streets
demanding social justice the young
rockers joined in and marched too we
just want to be treated like human
beings and not get killed it's not too
much to ask like i feel like it's really
not
what do you think about if people were
watching this and they say to themselves
wow this is just too much to put on a 12
year old i think it's good for kids to
stand up for social justice because
we're gonna be the next adults
[Music]
another layer for the alphabet rockers
making the world safer for lgbtq youth
studies show suicidal thoughts in
transgender youth decrease by 34 percent
when their preferred name and pronoun
are used
eleven-year-old heiress who performed
with the group is gender fluid what
pronouns do you use um i use they them
pronouns do people ask a lot of
questions
sometimes they want me to explain a lot
my gender is always changing so this
whole thing allowed you to feel more
like yourself
i think so yeah
the rockers are working on a new album
to be released next year
they hope the new songs will be both a
link to the past
[Music]
and a bridge to the future
i hope that families can have
conversations about what's going on in
the world racism ageism sexism all the
isms we're gonna be leading everybody
soon and it's important that we know we
have that power from a young age to say
what we believe is right
[Music]
i also want you to remember to be who
you are
because you shine and you're a rock star
it's music with a message making the
world better one beat at a time
for cbs this morning jamie yukas los
angeles
i love it yeah just the fact that kids
are more in touch with the world around
them and their emotions when we talk to
dr suzuki about good anxiety this is how
you learn to deal with that you address
the concerns that they have from an
early age and you do it with music okay
we're going to get that album yeah i
know we've got some little ones
yeah
why not listen i'll buy that i'll buy
that